what is always alleviated our scarcity
what is always alleviated our
environmental problems technology what
breeds technological dynamism economic
success economic stability hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason TV and today we're
talking with Joshua Jacobs he's with the
conservative future project thanks for
joining us thanks so much Nick describe
for us in your words what is the
conservative future project the
conservative future project is a pro
science pro technology organization and
you guys in your kind of mission
statement you're online you talk about
wanting to increase scientific
advancement using unbridled force of the
free market to bring America back to
unrivaled prosperity this all sounds
good but why are you conservative one of
the things that we wanted to do is that
we wanted to show that when you approach
deregulation when you approach tax cuts
when you approach entitlement reform and
put us on a sander fiscal path you can
create the environment that allows these
exciting new technologies to come about
specifically when it comes to regulation
we think there's no contest between
conservatives and liberals when it comes
to the tech field Manhattan Institute
came out with a big report about a year
ago that indicated that about ninety
percent of the development budget of
biotech companies is consumed in the
phase 3 clinical trial phase 3 fda
clinical trial one can only imagine how
much more would have been accomplished
how much more would have been brought to
market how much more would have been
discovered if those burdens were not so
burdensome right talk a bit about
driverless cars this is and you know
this is something that you know is kind
of both interesting and evocative of a
voucher this is like a Jetsons future
and you you've already tousled or the
idea of driverless cars is driving yeah
certain reliable parts of the Democratic
Party nuts I mean you guys hate this
idea oh yeah how is driverless cars a
conservative issue and what does it mean
for America's future everybody and their
mother is writing about the legal
implications for driverless cars how our
insurance actuary is going to deal with
driverless cars almost no one aside from
a select few have written about what the
actual impact is going to be on
driverless cars and it almost comes with
perennial problem that we have where we
see this technology off in the distance
it's not that far off in the distance
but we can't really tell how far what
happens when you have instead of three
and a half million truck drivers maybe
you only have a hundred thousand truck
drivers left because the rest of those
trucks are being driven by autonomous
artificial intelligence running the
highways there is no way we think
Teamsters are going to give up without a
fight there's no reason to if you're
them you know fight fight for your
livelihood this is something you have to
get out in front of right now if you
want to make sure that we can leap the
benefits of these new technology because
there are benefits talk you know talk
about stem cell research now because
this is you know to jump from an area
the automation I can see that an easy
sell not only to the show in public but
to conservatives but then we talk about
something like stem cells and you know
the possibilities inherent in that apart
from people like Nancy Reagan has you
aim at in favor of it most Republicans
are against that yeah most national
Republicans how do you get them to sign
on to something which they say no this
is should Rubicon that we're not going
to cross it seems highly unlikely to me
and I think most people would agree that
roe v wade is going to be overturned to
the next 20 years that by 2030 2040
abortion will still be legal in the
united states and it'll still be legal
most places in the world it is folly to
not allow ourselves to take advantage of
the medical and scientific opportunities
that come with that regardless how you
feel about it because it can save
millions and millions of lives and
improve the quality of lives without
exaggeration for billions that's the
message that we would try and bring but
we're not going to compromise on our
position we support stem cell research
we support medical research we support
medical science talk a little bit about
where are the issues that the left is
terrible on science and you know where
do they have to be held account to show
they're actually not pro future sure the
biggest one that I can think of is
probably in electricity what no one ever
calls Democrats and no one ever calls
the green left out on is that the
proposals that their advocate
for directly inhibit billions of human
beings access to all of the things that
we take for granted and what we say is
don't turn the power off turn the power
on build that coal power plant build
that natural gas back no and now but how
do you deal with things like global
warming air pollution I mean is that
just not an issue or what is what's the
conservative future projects response to
making sure that we're all breathing in
another hundred years I don't know if I
can give the conservative future
projects answer but I can give my answer
my position is this one I think a lot of
climatologists are on the ball when they
say it's probably unlikely that we're
going to be able to have a serious
impact just with restricting our
technology restricting our output on
climate change what's going to happen is
almost certainly going to happen
regardless of what we do in the next
even even if we stop now yeah even if
its top eight days and whatever's going
but what has always taken us out of
these holes in the past what is always
alleviated our scarcity what is always
alleviated our environmental problems
technology what breeds technological
dynamism economic success economic
stability if you want to solve these
problems and deal and mitigate with
these problems mitigate these problems
you need to have a healthy economy you
need to have an environment that allows
and accelerates the production of these
new technologies and you need to have it
sooner rather than later well we'll
leave it there Joshua Jacobs the group
is conservative few to the conservative
future project for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you